México ha sufrido tanta corrupción política y
durante tanto tiempo, que ha provocado que hoy un
líder como Andrés Manual López Obrador, antipremio
VisualPolitik, sea un político muy popular a pesar
de todos los suspensos que ha cosechado
en sus pocos años al frente del gobierno.
AMLO no es el clásico populista que grita
e insulta, pero sí que tiene muy afinada
la que quizás es la cualidad más
importante de todo buen político:
sabe ofrecer a los ciudadanos exactamente
lo que más quieren en cada momento.
¿Qué los anteriores presidentes
vivían a todo trapo? Pues, AMLO
lo tiene claro, por ejemplo, he aquí unas
cuantas medidas: viajar en clase turista,
convertir la residencia presidencial de los
Pinos en una especie de centro cultural y
prescindir el 787 presidencial. Con el cual por
cierto parece que nadie sabe qué demonios hacer.
El caso es que decisiones de este
estilo despiertan la simpatía popular.
Y no me malinterpretéis, muchas de estas cosas
pueden estar bien, sobre todo si tenemos en
cuenta el lujoso tren de vida que caracteriza
a los presidentes y altos políticos mexicanos.
Pero… El problema es cuando con estas
cosas se pretende justificar toda la
acción del gobierno. Y es peor aún cuando se
persigue que el apoyo popular cosechado sirva
para tapar que la economía vaya regular o
que la gestión de la pandemia fuera mala.
El caso es que pese a los altísimos índices
de criminalidad, la economía renqueante y la
pandemia, López Obrador mantiene un nivel
de aprobación muy alto entre los electores
mexicanos. Tan alto como los palos que
seguro nos van a caer por este vídeo.
Queridos amigos, amigas, López Obrador
es popularmente conocido como AMLO,
para abreviar. Claro que el que
no abrevia es el propio AMLO.
Prácticamente todos los días y para mayor
gloria del presidente, sease para él mismo,
da ruedas de prensa que se extienden por más
de dos horas. Y la pregunta es, ¿Es que acaso
el presidente de un país como México no tiene
nada mejor que hacer? Pues parece ser que no.
Fijaos.
(La guerra es sinónimo de
irracionalidad)
6 palabras en 19 segundos. Con ruedas de prensa
taan largas a veces ya no sabes ni que decir.
Pero, ¿Por qué en VisualPolitik hablamos de
AMLO? Pues, queridos amigos, amigas, no bajéis
la guardia ante este abuelito afable y cuando
quiere también simpático y hasta enternecedor.
Y digo que no bajéis al guardia porque
la Presidencia de AMLO está llevando a
cabo lo que se conoce como la Cuarta
Transformación de México. Un plan
político que consiste en poner punto y
final, derogar, derribar las reformas
de sus predecesores para poner en marcha sus
propias iniciativas en todo tipo de campos.
El problema es que las iniciativas
de AMLO tienen mucho que ver con las
típicas políticas latinoamericanas que
una y otra y otra vez se han demostrado
fallidas y que pueden terminar por
ahuyentar la inversión productiva.
Eso es, precisamente lo que está pasando con
el sector energético en dos ámbitos muy claros.
Por un lado está la reforma eléctrica. Por otro,
el rumbo que ha tomado la petrolera
estatal Pemex bajo esta presidencia.
Y, ¿Sabéis qué? Es la reforma energética de AMLO
a la que queremos echar un vistazo en este vídeo.
¿Qué está pasando en el sector
petrolero de México? ¿En qué
consiste la reforma eléctrica de
AMLO? Y lo que es más importante:
¿Cómo pueden afectar todas estas medidas a
la economía de México? Hoy en VisualPolitik
vamos a responder a estas preguntas. Pero
antes, vamos a ver un poco de historia.
(EL MONOPOLIO ESTATAL)
Hace justo un siglo México era el segundo
mayor productor de petróleo del mundo,
tan solo por detrás de Estados Unidos.
En aquel momento, el sector estaba dominado
por compañías extranjeras. La antaño dominante
Compañía Mexicana El Águila había sido adquirida
por la angloholandesa Royal Dutch Shell. También
había un montón de compañías estadounidenses
que operaban al sur de la frontera.
Pero, sin embargo, pronto perdieron el
interés en los yacimientos mexicanos.
Los ingleses comenzaron a explotar el petróleo en
Oriente Medio y los estadounidenses en Venezuela.
Y es que, veréis, el problema para estas
compañías es que el movimiento obrero
era uno de los pilares sobre los que se
apoyaba el presidente Lázaro Cárdenas.
Cuando llegaron, las petroleras no tenían ni la
más remota idea del lío en
el que se estaban metiendo.
(Un conflicto laboral saltó en 1938 a la arena
política cuando las petroleras intentaron no
acatar una sentencia de la Suprema Corte a
favor de las demandas de los trabajadores.
Al intentar evitar cumplir con el fallo,
las compañías extranjeras vieron cómo un
asunto laboral se convirtió en toda una
disputa sobre la soberanía de la nación.
Así que el presidente Lázaro Cárdenas
intervino directamente en el asunto
decretando la nacionalización de la industria
petrolera. Tres meses después Cárdenas decretó
la creación de Petróleos Mexicanos,
Pemex, la empresa estatal que recibía
el monopolio para explotar y administrar
los yacimientos de petróleo del país.)
La jugada a México pareció salirle
de perlas. ¿Por qué? Pues digamos
que en los años 40 Estados Unidos y Reino
Unido tenían otras preocupaciones mucho
más importantes que pasarle la factura a México.
Además, la Segunda Guerra Mundial y el crecimiento
económico de la posguerra incrementaron
considerablemente la demanda de crudo, con lo que
la nacionalización se convirtió en un gran necio.
Y ojo, porque el petrolero no fue el
único ámbito energético intervenido por
el presidente Cárdenas. Antes ya había
sido el turno del sector eléctrico.
(En 1937 Cárdenas fundó la CFE, la
Comisión Federal de Electricidad.
Su propósito era operar en el sector sin
ánimo de lucro basándose exclusivamente en
principios técnicos. El objetivo era obtener
el mayor rendimiento posible al mínimo coste.
Esto hizo que las compañías privadas solo
se interesaran por las zonas más rentables,
las principales ciudades y
las zonas industrializadas.
Así que para la Comisión Federal de Electricidad
quedaron las áreas rurales y dispersas.)
Evidentemente este sistema no funcionó.
Era una ruina para la empresa estatal
y encima más de la mitad de los mexicanos
seguían sin suministro eléctrico. Así que,
¿qué solución creéis que
adoptó el Gobierno de México?
A ver, quizás, ¿Liberalizar el mercado, favorecer
la competencia e incentivar
la inversión, por ejemplo?
Pues no, para nada
En 1960 el presidente Adolfo López
Mateos completó la nacionalización
del sector eléctrico. ¿Y sabéis qué?
En un primer momento tampoco pareció
salirles mal. México tenía recursos más
que suficientes como para hacer frente a
las malas decisiones y mantener enormes
subsidios al consumo de electricidad.
Pensad que los países con petróleo
eran los nuevos ricos del panorama
internacional. Y más a partir de los años 70.
(Las crisis del petróleo de 1973 y de 1979
dispararon el precio del crudo, multiplicando los
ingresos de Pemex por sus exportaciones. Además,
en 1979 comenzó a operar el Complejo Cantarell,
uno de los mayores yacimientos del mundo.
El problema es que los Gobiernos mexicanos
tenían el control completo sobre la petrolera y no
la dirigían con una mentalidad empresarial. Todo
lo contrario, la exprimían con múltiples
impuestos y regalías con los que nutrir
las arcas del Estado. Lo que dejó a PEMEX con
muchos menos recursos para invertir y crecer)
El complejo Cantarell alcanzó
su pico de producción en 2004.
Aquel año fue también el de mayor
producción de la historia de Pemex:
3,4 millones de barriles diarios de
crudo. Desde entonces ha caído en
picado ejercicio tras ejercicio hasta
situarse entorno a la mitad en 2020.
Claro que ante el declive de Cantarell, el remedio
fue casi peor que la enfermedad. Pemex invirtió
70.000 millones de dólares entre los años 2008
y 2012 en la exploración y producción de crudo.
El problema es que la mayor parte lo invirtió
en áreas para las que Pemex estaba técnicamente
mal preparada, como la perforación en aguas
profundas o el fracking. El desastre estaba
garantizado. Para colmo las inversiones
se hicieron fundamentalmente con deuda
porque el gobierno mexicano no estaba
dispuesto a dejar de recibir sus cheques.
Así que la crisis de Pemex se agudizó
con estas malas decisiones de inversión.
Y si a todo esto le sumamos la corrupción que
dominó la compañía durante décadas y una toma
de decisiones de corte más política
que empresarial que, por ejemplo,
hizo que la petrolera tuviera una plantilla mucho
más grande de lo necesaria, lo que nos encontramos
es precisamente con una petrolera endeudada
hasta las cejas y con una producción menguante.
La joya de México estaba a
punto de caer. Para evitarlo
estaba claro que había que cambiar muchas cosas.
Y esa papeleta le tocó ni más ni menos que
a uno de los gobiernos más manchados por
corrupción y peor valorados en la historia
de México: el de Enrique Peña Nieto.
Así que, claro, daba igual lo que se hiciera,
cualquier medida quedaría manchada. Incluso
aunque la reforma fuese en buena dirección.
(La reforma energética de 2013 acabó con el
monopolio estatal de Pemex sobre el sector
petrolero, abriéndolo a la inversión privada. Se
permitió que las empresas extranjeras pujaran en
subastas transparentes retransmitidas online
por hacerse con la exploración y producción de
campos petroleros. También se abrió el camino
a reducir el número de trabajadores de Pemex,
que ha pasado de 151.000 empleados en
2013 a los 120.000 de la actualidad.
Se completaron 9 subastas petroleras hasta que
se paralizaron en julio de 2018,
cuando AMLO ganó las elecciones.)
El balance a día de hoy es que en aquellas
subastas se adjudicaron 111 campos y 34
ya iniciaron su explotación. Hasta el momento
se invirtieron 18.000 millones de dólares. La
renta petrolera del Estado mexicano establecida
en los contratos es de aproximadamente un 74%,
uno de los mayores porcentajes en
el mundo. ¿Qué quiere decir esto?
Pues básicamente que la reforma atrajo
multimillonarias inversiones de empresas
extranjeras. Compañías privadas que arriesgan su
dinero en explorar y extraer el petróleo pero que
luego le pagan al Estado mexicano la mayor parte
de los ingresos derivados de su producción. Todo
ello sin que el Gobierno mexicano invierta un
solo peso. Parece un buen business, ¿no os parece?
Pues como siempre hay alguien que no está
de acuerdo. Así se pronunciaba AMLO cuando
era el líder de la oposición.
(Si nos quitan el petróleo,
sería como desangrar a México. )AMLO planteó una
oposición feroz contra la reforma energética de
Peña Nieto. Como buen populista, llegó a
prometer que haría un referéndum para que
el pueblo se pronunciara sobre la misma. Pero
amigos, una cosa es la política y otra gobernar.
En diciembre de 2018 AMLO tomaba posesión
como presidente de México. Es decir,
que ha pasado tiempo suficiente para empezar a ver
qué está pasando con la política
energética de este presidente.
Atentos.
(DAME MÁS
GASOLINA)
López Obrador ha hecho consultas populares
de todo tipo: para ver si construía una
línea ferroviaria o un aeropuerto.
Pero la consulta prometida sobre qué
hacer con la reforma energética...
pues no. Esa quedo en el olvido.
Claro que eso no ha evitado que Pemex
siga siendo un quebradero de cabeza
para el Gobierno de México. Porque aunque
AMLO hable de la petrolera estatal como si
fuera la joya de la Corona, la
realidad es ya muy diferente.
Los años pasan y las pérdidas se acumulan
para Pemex. Algo difícil de entender cuando
extraer un barril de crudo le cuesta
una media de 7 dólares y lo vende por
10 veces más. Claro que, luego, el Estado
mexicano asfixia a Pemex con impuestos.
Pensad que un tercio del gasto público del
país azteca es sostenido por los recursos
extraídos de la petrolera estatal. Y si a
eso le sumamos que el resto de negocios de
Pemex son una auténtica ruina, pues
no sorprenden noticias como esta:
(Pemex, entre las 10 compañías más
endeudadas del planeta. Forbes)
Hablamos ni más ni menos que de una deuda
de más de 100.000 millones de dólares. Una
deuda que además no para de marcar cada
nuevo tiempo nuevos récords históricos.
Así que López Obrador se ha puesto manos
a la obra para reflotar a la petrolera
estatal. Lo primero que ha hecho AMLO es
aprobar una nueva Ley de Hidrocarburos
con el propósito de favorecer a Pemex en
el mercado de las estaciones de servicio.
Luego, respecto a la apertura a la
inversión extranjera en los campos
petroleros mexicanos, AMLO apostó por revisar
los contratos ya adjudicados para
comprobar si hubo o no corrupción.
Además, como ya hemos visto, se suspendieron las
subastas petroleras desde el mismo
momento en que ganó las elecciones.
Recientemente lo más peligroso para México es
que su Gobierno ha querido ir un paso más allá
y ha actuado directamente contra los intereses
de un consorcio que ya ha invertido 325 millones
de dólares en México y está encabezado por
la petrolera estadounidense Talos VEnergy.
El resultado de estas medidas es que se
ha lanzado un mensaje muy negativo hacia
los inversores. ¿Y todo para qué? Pues
para beneficiar a los mismos de siempre.
(El mayor hallazgo privado de petróleo de
México será operado por la estatal Pemex)
De momento, el resultado es que a pesar
de todo, cuando AMLO llegó al poder la
empresa petrolera mexicana producía 1,8
millones de barriles. Hoy la cifra está
en torno a los 1,6 millones. Y todo apunta
a que las cosas no van a mejorar mucho.
Luego, si algo sorprende de la economía
mexicana es que un país que tiene tantos
yacimientos de petróleo se vea obligado a importar
combustibles porque sus refinerías
son de los tiempos de Pancho Villa.
Se trata de una anomalía que AMLO se ha
propuesto resolver. El problema es que la
factura está acumulando demasiados ceros.
De momento se han invertido más de 6.000
millones en modernizar las refinerías de
la petrolera estatal y en comprar a Shell
la mitad de una refinería en Texas cuya
propiedad estaba compartida con Pemex.
Lo cual si lo pensáis no tiene mucho sentido.
¿Para qué poner fin a una sociedad con Shell
que ha funcionado tan bien cuándo PEMEX
gestiona mucho peor sus propios activos?
Pero esperad un momento, porque
eso prácticamente no es nada si
lo comparamos con los casi 9.000 millones
de dólares que AMLO se está gastando en uno
de sus proyectos estrella: construir una
refinería en su estado natal de Tabasco.
AMLO no quiere que nada se interponga
entre Pemex y la autosuficiencia de México
para producir combustibles. Y cuando
decimos nada, os aseguro que es nada.
(Pemex está construyendo una refinería en
un espacio natural que prometió proteger)
La cuestión es que el Gobierno mexicano
está ahora mismo poniendo toda la carne
en el asador para que el país produzca todos
los combustibles que consume para el año 2023.
El problema es que tal y como hemos
visto lo hace siguiendo una receta muy
similar a la que México ha seguido años
atrás: Petróleo, nacionalismo y mucho
intervencionismo sin tener excesivamente
en cuanto los criterios empresariales.
Bien, todo esto sobre el petróleo,
pero qué ocurre con el otro brazo
de la reforma energética ¿Qué
pasa con el sector eléctrico?
Pues… Atentos.
(LA REFORMA CONSTITUCIONAL)
La nacionalización de 1960 convirtió
al sector eléctrico en un monopolio
estatal en manos de la Comisión Federal de
Electricidad. Así fue hasta los años 90,
cuando se produjo una tímida
apertura al sector privado.
Se puso en marcha el llamado modelo de autoabasto,
un mecanismo que permitía a las empresas esquivar
a la Comisión y comprar electricidad a plantas
de generación de compañías eléctricas privadas
en una fórmula similar a los PPAs, es decir,
los contratos de compraventa de energía.
La apertura al sector privado cobró fuerza
con la reforma energética de Peña Nieto,
que impulsó la inversión en generación
eléctrica. Se estableció un mercado
mayorista de electricidad que daba
prioridad a los proveedores de
energía más baratos y renovables. ¿Suena
bastante bien, verdad? Pues para AMLO no.
Como Peña Nieto relegó a
la CFE a un segundo plano,
AMLO dedicó buena parte de sus esfuerzos
durante 2021 a poner en marcha una reforma
eléctrica que reforzara a la
Comisión, séase al gobierno.
(La reforma eléctrica de AMLO causó gran polémica
al cambiar el orden de despacho de energía por
parte de las centrales. En primer lugar entrarían
en funcionamiento las hidroeléctricas y las
centrales de fuel y carbón de la CFE. En segundo
lugar, los ciclos combinados de gas que generan
su energía para la Comisión. Tras esas plantas,
se daría paso a los parques privados de energía
eólica y solar. Y por último, los ciclos
combinados de gas de compañías privadas.)
Pero vamos a ver: ¿A quién se le ocurre dar
prioridad a las térmicas sobre las renovables?
La eólica y la solar tienen que funcionar cuando
hay sol y viento. Y cuando no lo hay, pues pones
a funcionar a las térmicas. Si no, pues no tiene
mucho sentido. De primero de sistema eléctrico.
El caso es que López Obrador
aprobó esta reforma hace meses,
pero un tribunal la paralizó. En un país con
seguridad jurídica, aquí se hubiera acabado
la reforma eléctrica. En el México de AMLO, no.
(El presidente de México amenaza con un cambio
constitucional si se anula la ley energética)
Y como decimos por aquí, dicho y hecho.
El problema a priori del presidente mexicano es
que no dispone de la mayoría
suficiente para aprobarla.
Y ahora ya no se habla de orden de despacho
sino de cuotas. Se pretende garantizar que
las centrales de la CFE produzcan un
54% de la electricidad de México. Y
ahora os preguntaréis: ¿A qué viene tanto empeño?
Pues básicamente a que en 2020 entró en vigor
una nueva regulación internacional que limita
el azufre del combustible que utilizan las
navieras. Hasta entonces este era uno de los
principales mercados para el fuel que producían
las refinerías de Pemex, tan obsoletas que se
han mostrado incapaces de reducir sus niveles
de azufre. Así que este es el objetivo de AMLO:
poner a las térmicas de la CFE a quemar el
fuel que nadie le quiere comprar a Pemex.
Todo ello aunque contamine mucho más
y sus costes de generación sean para
colmo un 25% superiores a los de las
nuevas plantas renovables. Es decir,
que a AMLO le da igual que México produzca
una energía más cara o más sucia. Lo único
que le preocupa es reflotar las empresas
estatales mexicanas al precio que sea.
Y si al final eso supone aumentar
los subsidios para que no suba la
factura que los mexicanos pagan por su
electricidad, pues nada, a tirar de chequera.
Y aún con todo eso no es lo peor. Fijaos.
(Con la reforma de AMLO México no solo tendrá
energía más cara y más sucia sino que además,
viendo el panorama, peligran inversiones por valor
de 40.000 millones de dólares
en energía eólica y solar.
Todo esto resulta preocupante para el
futuro de México porque se suma al bajón
que está sufriendo en las inversiones
desde que AMLO ganó las elecciones.
Lo que puede terminar convirtiéndose en
una oportunidad perdida ahora que las
multinacionales están buscando diversificar sus
cadenas de suministro fuera de China. Pero es
que los inversores no se fían del presidente
mexicano. Los datos hablan por sí solos.)
Pero llegados hasta aquí la pregunta es para ti:
¿Veis bien que se prioricen los
intereses de las empresas estatales
sobre la instalación de renovables? ¿Qué os
parecen las reformas emprendidas por AMLO?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios. Y como siempre, si este
vídeo os ha resultado interesante no olvidéis
darle a Like y suscribiros a VisualPolitik.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.